first of all good morning Congrats on
the movie what I was interested to learn
when I was researching you know to talk
to you guys what I didn't realize was
you started earlier in your career doing
voice stuff leading to Despicable Me as
well
yeah the first and second ones yeah
exactly and you've done you know at
least a little bit of voice work so I'm
sorry I thought you were gonna say
something no I just I was prepared to
but no this is sure what it was gonna be
I was gonna say that I was curious since
you both have experience with this how
did this process making this compare to
what you've done in the past or is it
all like very similar I tell you it's
similar in one way and that you don't
never like lc9 just met
yeah there's ago okay and and she plays
my my daughter and in this version of
The Addams Family and that that's the
one part of it that's just always odd to
me but but it's still it's a lot of fun
to do I love being a part of these
things but one time I'm determined to do
it one where we all get to be in the
same room and I mean it happens
occasionally no I haven't and I mean
this this was different for me and
experience because like when I did the
Despicable Me Films and you know some of
my other stuff I was so young that for a
lot of them I couldn't actually read so
they would say the lines me the way they
wanted no parrot it back how old were
you when you did your first one five
that's incredible I didn't start my
career I was 35 it's just incredible we
have two opposite experiences in this
business um one of the things that I
find fascinating about the animated
process is that so much can change while
you're making the movie yeah so how did
this one change for both the film and
your characters yeah I mean I think I
was brought on pretty I don't know later
into the process so I think a lot of it
was already set up but it's been
interesting to see the film really like
just develop and become a thing
cuz I don't know when you when you're
doing it you just see like little clip
it's and your parts or at least I did so
it's been awesome to kind of see it come
to fruition
I had a interesting journey with this
one as I saw the first rendering of
Margo and I thought she looks kind of
like Dolly Parton
so I did a whole version of Margo with
the southern accent and that didn't it
didn't jive well with the rest of the
movie so they they had me redo it in a
different voice and so that was one that
was an interesting journey and then a
lot of the the town that Margo makes
over that name changed about a hundred
times and I just
it's called assimilation now but yeah
I've sort of I've been a you know those
changes happen up until right two
minutes ago I heard there were like you
guys are doing like some ads if you will
like a month ago or a month and half or
at least Chloe did was that did happen
with you guys um I don't know I think I
had my last stuff a while back cuz I've
been anything Massachusetts very well
itself yeah I don't I did I did do some
press a couple weeks ago but I and we
did a video with a snaps Church is
really fun to do but yeah completely uh
one of the things about the Addams
Family is they've been around for a very
long time and what do you think it is
about the Addams family that has
resonated through like generations and I
think it's a it resonates because it's
about it's about families and it's about
acceptance it's about love it's about
tradition and those are themes that that
are always worth exploring over and over
again and they're there it's a movie
that parents can take go to with their
kids and and it's it's just an enjoyable
fun and it's really timeless to like it
applies you know I don't know I mean
that's why it's happening again now
another incarnation because it's so
relevant now but you know we've had it
for so long the animal family throughout
the years so I think it's just I don't
know it applies to everyone
yeah um I want to or two individual
questions are you when you signed on to
moms were you are you surprised at the
how popular the show ended up becoming
um I you know you're always surprised
and in the television world these days
because there's so many different
platforms so many different shows to
watch you don't know if you're gonna
sink or swim so I'm
really grateful that people are watching
mom because it's because I'm really I'm
really proud of the message we put out
there and what we're saying and showing
people in recovery and showing that
there's hope in recovery rooms and
laughter and and that's an important
message that I'm proud to be a part of
putting out into the world so two more
seasons I have an individual for you I
am very excited for Council Rock season
to and I believe Massachusetts is where
you work
yes what can you what can you tease
about it I think uh fans who did not see
season one will really like it and fans
who did sees it
see season one will like it even more
and it is very good and Lizzy Caplan is
amazing see she's so good yeah she's
okay I'm like we call a few oh you a few
funner quite or fun questions and you
can let me know in about 30 seconds if
you like them or not right um what TV
show would you love to guest star on
whoa killing Eva Oh
same it was sad I look like you do Jody
comer yeah so I mean when the flash sad
news that happens I know Eddie perfect
um what movie do you think you've seen
the most Groundhog Day
um do you have a favorite ride at
Disneyland oh um don't do roids
Matterhorn okay is there anything that
you collect dogs I'm gonna do Ella three
going to go for four are they I'm
assuming did you adopt yep they're all
rescues there are all Australian Cattle
Dog mutts and I just can't get enough of
dogs is there any place in LA or where
you adopted from that you would like to
recommend to people um you know I got I
rescue to in in Mississippi and one of
them here I just went on rescue rescue
pet calm but best friends is a great
place to really
of helping them out in any way I can
there's so many great places just adopt
just adopt I always say adopt don't shop
adopt oh yeah yeah is there anything
that you collect uh yeah pins and
patches when I was shooting eighth grade
I have this hat and I got a pin from
every place we traveled to while we were
shooting and when I was filming Castle
Rock I have this jacket and it's it's a
denim jacket and I just had patches from
everywhere oh cool all right
yeah what TV show do you think you've
watched all the way through more than
once the office that was very fast I
mean so fast okay she's uh I'm stumped
stuff to me okay is there any I'll let
you think of nothing I don't Donna you
don't want to do that right anyways all
your topic my last thing for you what
was the last thing you were really
obsessed with well I'm learning to play
the guitar right now and I'm kind of
obsessed with it so I keep one he said
if it could up my fingers are killing me
but I keep obsessing about the cord hand
positions and chords them absurd that's
my current obsession Ida yeah I mean I
love music also that's great
but right now it's probably video games
for me and like the Nintendo switch I
think it is maybe the greatest thing
ever invented so